I'm hoping this is fun and doesn't just
come across as tacky so uh that intro
bit you just saw with the title I don't
know if I've ever mentioned before or at
least I don't think I've mentioned it
since I first started using it but
that's fan-made I didn't make that I
don't know how to do that and you know
he
that's from mr. mashup he gets credited
in the end credits and I thought it
would be fun to basically offer up kind
of a an opening intro contest maybe a
bumper contest would be the way to put
now maybe that's not it I'm pulling that
cos link card did something similar and
I'm not trying to rip him off I swear to
God
but basically I have a number of things
that I think it'd be really neat to just
kind of toss out there if anybody has
any interest in taking a crack at doing
intro bits for us for them obviously
there's you know the sort of the main
show if you wanted to do something
stylized for a specific topic something
stylized for Doctor Who for I actually I
actually have one stylized Star Wars I
forgot to use it last time I talked
about Star Wars but I've got that one
waiting the wings you know things like
that
animation junkie that'd be cool to have
its own intro bit nitpick rants good
movie bad ending also coming up what
will I'll finally drop that I'm
definitely doing this because I think I
finally have my ducks in a row no
promises on when it goes live but my
podcast 90s comics retrial is going to
be making its video debut this year so
that could use an intro to be honest so
here's how this is gonna work I'm gonna
consider the contest closed on September
the 15th so between now and then
anyone would any interest in taking a
crack at any of this you can create
intros you can use original art you can
use any clips from any of my previous
things
anything like that here's what you can't
do or at least if you do this I'll still
appreciate it but I won't use it you
can't use video footage of anything that
isn't from my videos so you can't I
would prefer that you're not trying to
insert video footage from Doctor Who
from you know Star Wars from anything
else because that's the kind of stuff
that I I just I just don't use because
I'm trying to avoid you know the
copyright issues so that's the first
thing as far as music goes there's
obviously there's the council of geeks
theme 90's comics retrial also has its
own theme I'm gonna make those available
I believe it's I think I'm gonna set up
a Dropbox that will be accessible to
people want to go and get these tracks
to be able to use them so I would
encourage you to use those if you want
to do original music you can do that if
you want to use music that isn't what
I'm making available to you you can but
it needs to be from something like Kevin
MacLeod an incompetent you know it's a
royalty-free something of that nature
now and I also if you do that I also
need to know where you got it because
even though it's royalty-free whoever
did it it's gonna be credited and that's
my big thing and that's sort of the main
thing that I have I know I hesitated
calling a contest because I don't have
that big of thing to offer besides have
my using it and and you get mentioned in
the credits for it and for those who won
but that also gets you an IMDB credits
yeah this is listed on IMDB haha so all
of that and also you know what um we'll
toss in a merch bundle so the the colors
bundle them merch stuff it's a magnet
there's a button there is a keychain
that a sign business card so who will
sweeten the pot on on whatever ones
actually get used all of that assuming
you're willing to provide me with your
mailing details if you don't want to
that's fine but so that's yeah
that's it I'm really kind of curious and
nervous that like nobody's going to do
it because nobody cares but who knows I
I know that I've got more than a few
fairly creative subscribers and like
I'll just toss this out the guy's doing
my thumbnails now he just reached out to
me I didn't find him he found me
offering to start to do this and we've
come to Arrangements since then and he's
doing phenomenal work obviously more
than a few people have noted how much
better my thumbnails are now so you know
I've always loved hearing from you know
from you guys with anything that you you
feel like putting out there so yeah the
links the link to the Dropbox with the
music tracks that'll be down in the
description and now yo of course my
emails down there for you to you know
send the information to me and give it a
shot you know what what do you have to
lose and depending on how many I get cuz
I honest I have zero scope is zero
concept of how big or small this could
be I I'm half expecting like three
entries I'm kind of afraid that is gonna
be a lot I say afraid but like it would
be overwhelming in a good way to get
like a ton of them but depending on what
I get I might put together like a
compilation of even the ones that I
don't use just so people can still get
some recognition we'll see but yeah just
tossing it out there hey if you're
inclined if you like taking a crack at
this stuff if you if you have an idea
you feel inspired with any of the things
that I mentioned go for it give it a
shot so links for everything will be
down in the description and yeah I'll
end it on that note folks because I want
to involve my subscribers my the
community as much as I can because you
are the council and I only run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]